- Good Morning.
I hope you're having an amazing day.
It's Mark Wiens.
I'm in Chiang Mai, Thailand.
And if you ask someone
from northern Thailand
what is their comfort food,
it's quite likely that they would say
(speaking foreign language).
It's an amazing dish.
I mean anyway, we'll talk
more about that later.
But today is a very special day.
We're driving out to
Three Trees Doi Saket,
which is, it's about an hour away.
And we're gonna meet my friend, Hanuman.
Hanuman is a great friend
of mine, we go way back,
and he is one of the most knowledgeable,
he is the most knowledgeable person
about Thai food that I know.
He's a master of Thai food
and he runs a professional cooking class.
And so today we're gonna have
an honor to go to his place.
We're gonna see the cooking.
We're gonna eat.
It's just gonna be a lot of fun
and I'm gonna share it all with
you in this video right now.
(upbeat music)
We're getting close,
but the mountains are
just incredibly beautiful.
The greenery,
the misty peaks.
- In 600 meters, turn right.
- And just to quickly
tell you about Hanuman.
Hanuman is a great friend of mine.
We've been friends for many years.
And formerly, he was based in Bangkok.
But I had been following
his entire journey.
He bought this plot of land
in Chiang Mai in Doi Saket
and it was originally like a swampy area
that he fully developed,
he had the full vision.
And so I had been following
along the progress,
him posting photos, he built a house,
and that is now Three Trees Doi Saket.
So this is exciting for me
because I'm finally gonna have a chance
to visit Hanuman here in Chiang Mai
and we'll have a chance to cook and eat
and, yeah, it's just gonna be
so much fun and so beautiful.
(upbeat music)
Yes, there, check that out.
Oh wait, tree.
Oh yes, Hanuman.
Chili bush, right there.
Can you pick a chili right
out of the window, Ying?
(laughing)
- Ah, ready to eat?
- OK.
That's my first bite at
Three Trees Doi Saket.
Don't tell Hanuman.
Oh, it's so good.
Mmm, it has this beautiful sourness to it.
- I can smell it.
Yeah, that's awesome.
Wow.
- Whew, yeah, that's spicy.
- [Hanuman] Hello.
- [Mark] Hello.
Good morning.
- Good morning, sir.
How are you?
- Good to see you.
Very good to see you.
Good, how are you?
- Was it a good, good drive?
- [Mark] Beautiful.
(speaking foreign language)
Beautiful drive.
Everyone say hello to Hanuman.
- Hello (speaking foreign language).
Hanuman.
- [Mark] And we've just arrived
to Three Trees Doi Saket.
It's an honor to be here.
On the way driving here,
I was mentioning how you had told me
the whole story of this place
and how you had--
- Yeah, it was a long--
- Transformed the entire property
and so it's so great to
actually be here in person now.
- Yeah, you're welcome, come.
- Thank you very much.
This is the.
Oh man, this is house is beautiful.
- [Hanuman] So the house
is basically stretched-out.
- Wow.
- So this is the kitchen.
This is the dining room.
Here we have an office
and a small living room.
The living quarters over there.
- [Mark] OK.
So those are the--
- Those are
the bedrooms.
- Those are your rooms.
OK.
- [Hanuman] So we have a
naturally underground stream.
- Hmm.
So we're just getting first the tour,
oh, be careful, Micah.
(speaking foreign language)
Be careful, man.
- Down, down.
- Come on, man.
- We're just getting
a quick tour walking around
the house and the compound,
but it's laid out so incredibly beautiful.
Thai style, yet with a modern touch.
- [Hanuman] Yeah.
- There's the kitchen and
there's the dining room
at the front here and then the next room
while walking on this
beautiful wooden deck.
These are the rooms here.
- [Hanuman] So this is.
This is our on-site
sewer treatment system.
- [Mark] Ah.
(upbeat music)
- [Hanuman] This is
where the magic happens.
- [Mark] Wow.
Fully like a commercial kitchen.
Even better.
- Yeah, that's a commercial kitchen, but
we have put the, all
the dry spices are here,
fresh ingredients here.
That's where the magic happens
and then we're ready to do
(speaking foreign language)
- Today.
- Today, yeah.
- Awesome.
But I know it's gonna
be like the next level
(speaking foreign language)
- I hope so.
I hope so.
- Yeah, for sure.
Guaranteed.
Anything that I've ever eaten with Hanuman
or Hanuman has cooked, it blows your mind,
just the next level, the care,
the research and the
zero shortcuts process
that he takes in all of his cooking.
The dish that we're gonna be focusing on,
that we're gonna be making today,
is called (speaking
foreign language) and--
- And (speaking foreign
language) means Shan people
or Shan people style,
so it basically means
(speaking foreign language)
or fresh rice noodles
with Shan style broth.
(speaking foreign language)
This is the cotton, we haven't used it.
What I do, I used it now, I
use (speaking foreign language)
and (speaking foreign
language) is from soy beans.
So I use (speaking foreign language).
And I use (speaking foreign language)
and I use soy sauce.
So you get all these levels of five
umamis going together.
- Yeah, those are all
like fermented ingredients
that just build in complexion with age.
And flavor.
- Just do red curries,
good color, nice aroma.
So what we're going to
do, we're going to do
a red curry paste, and
then we use an under paste.
So with the under paste,
we use fresh chili,
just to improve the color.
(speaking foreign language)
for northern tribes,
you either use mature
(speaking foreign language)
or in season you use
(speaking foreign language).
- You're making this purely on experience.
You know all the amounts.
You even, that comment that he made
about half the amount of
(speaking foreign language)
as chilis.
- You don't measure.
- A quarter.
In cooking, ratios are more
important than quantities.
- OK.
- So when you cook, you
have to think ratios,
rather than absolute quantities.
So if somebody say to you, OK,
take this, start to do the
(speaking foreign language),
you know how it throws
the domino by ratios.
(upbeat music)
And that's (speaking foreign language).
- So that is fermented fish.
- That's fermented fish.
And what we do, we take
the fermented fish,
and we put it on a bed of lemongrass
and (speaking foreign language).
Now what I do, I do many layers.
So then I can basically
put it on low heat.
And then I generate smoke.
- When that's finished
smoking, it's just gonna be
like flavor upon flavor upon flavor.
Fermented soybeans?
- Yeah.
Fermented soybeans.
- Made into a little.
- So again, when you
have smoke, it goes good
with the umami.
Let's do it third smoke.
So we do it.
We take the chilis,
and we need to rate rate it.
We would.
This will be loud.
- That's OK.
As soon as, it just started to blacken
just like a second, he tossed in water
because we don't want
to blacken the chili,
we don't want the black chilis,
we want to keep the chilis red,
but that's just gonna
increase the smoky flavor.
- If we are doing smoke,
so that's burned in one day.
- [Mark] OK, we'll have smoke and fire?
(laughing)
Coming right out of the pan.
Those have just like blistered up.
Oh, they're so fragrant.
- So I put tomatoes,
pink tomatoes, and charred tomatoes,
so you get three layers,
and you have one smoke, two smoke.
Three smoke, four smoke.
It's all about layering.
Counting your elements.
- Next level.
- Cut the nail.
- In the meantime, he's
preparing some of the ingredients
for the broth, including
chicken teeth and pork bones.
- [Hanuman] Now, the same
thing, you don't have to
deseed it first, you
basically just take it
and cut it into little chunks.
How is your pounding skills?
- Could be better.
For the gray paste.
- 54.
- 54 minutes?
54 minutes later, we
will have a smooth paste
with all of these ingredients
that we've been preparing.
All mingled together.
(upbeat music)
Oh, yes, (speaking foreign language).
- [Hanuman] So I put the
(speaking foreign language),
so it will be dry.
So it will be dry when I put the shallot.
- In goes that fermented soy bean wafer,
and then also the shallots next.
(speaking foreign language)
And that is the little
pile of fermented fish
that he smoked out in
the banana leaf packet.
What's so incredible to
hang out with Hanuman
as he cooks is the history,
the culture, and just the wisdom
that he brings with
Thai food and knowledge.
- In order to get signals,
you should have taste MSG.
Taste it.
- I've never done this before.
- Taste it.
- I usually order
without MSG.
- There is nothing
wrong with that, that's umami.
- Pure MSG.
- Oh yeah,
tastes like seaweed.
- So you didn't get a big sensation,
it's something in your mouth, right?
Now let's unlock it.
Take a cucumber and now taste it.
- Wow.
Yeah, it's like seaweedy.
Now with a cucumber?
- Yeah, take with
a cucumber.
You can do it.
- Mm, mmhmm.
Yep, yeah.
It does change the like
composition of it almost.
- The only free umami
flavor in nature is tomato.
Tomato has both
nucleotides and glutamates.
In one.
- That's cool.
- We put much attention to
layering our umami in the
(speaking foreign language).
So this is also an umami factor.
So you use big, you
use green, you use mid,
you use red, you use all the colors,
so you get layering of the same element.
And then you use then smoked, as well.
(speaking foreign language)
is the cotton tree.
I like to take a batch and deep fry it,
be crispy, so we can eat it.
Deep fried chilis and then we
have to do chili oil, as well.
- Hanuman is gonna do some of
his own fried crispy ingredients.
- This is a homemade
(speaking foreign language),
25 ingredients.
(upbeat music)
When I cook, I think about
the three dimensional flavor profile.
Where I have smoked fat umami
and then wrap it with
rice, spice it, slice it
with sours and swits and
elevate it with herbs.
Some people thinks that, you know,
once you do a curry
paste, you finish cooking.
No, you just started.
You created a new ingredient.
So I create an under paste,
and in the under paste, I
put things I want to show
on my top paste.
So in my top paste, I use fresh tomatoes.
So I don't have any fresh
ingredients in my paste.
I have dried chilis,
I have all the umami.
So I put layers of freshness under it
so I get another layer,
if you think about it
in three dimensions.
- So Hanuman is starting
on the under paste next.
- So, see, it's not much.
You use pork fat.
- All the components are prepared.
We're ready to start assembling curry,
it's a curry, yeah?
Curry paste, it's a curry.
- Anything that has a
paste in Thai is a gang.
- Gang.
(chattering)
Curry paste in there.
- Yeah, pork fat.
- Pork fat.
- Then curry paste.
- The under paste.
Oh, the under paste first.
Then the regular paste, and
then the minced pork went in.
Then he added in the stock
with the chicken feet
and the pork bones and then dropped in
all of the tomatoes,
the variety of tomatoes.
- We have saltiness from
(speaking foreign language).
And some salt, right?
- So this is a first
evaluation before adding.
- He did the two step.
(laughing)
When you are cooking Thai
food, it's essential,
it's mandatory that you taste.
(laughing)
Yes.
The (speaking foreign language)
you can taste in there nicely.
(chattering)
This is chicken?
- This is chicken.
- And then he just tossed
in the chicken blood jelly.
Curry is ready, it's simmered
for maybe 20 minutes or so?
- 15, 20 minutes.
- Yeah, wasn't that long.
And the dish is ready, the meal is cooked.
The paste was pounded,
and it was more about
assembling it all and then
just boiling it together
for a little bit.
But it's to be eaten with
(speaking foreign language),
which are the soft,
they're fresh rice noodles.
Beautiful, yes.
- Hanuman, thank you, thank you.
- Fascinating.
And that is mission complete.
Even the assembling was beautiful.
Combining those parts.
I mean, you've got the curry.
Then he added on those
roasted firework tomatoes.
Fried chilis and cotton flower.
Some chili oil.
Some fried garlic, some shallots,
some pickled mustard greens,
a Hawaiian wedge, it's
all there, it's all ready.
We're ready to eat.
(upbeat music)
(chattering)
Thank you, Hanuman, thank you so much.
- My pleasure.
- It's so beautiful.
It's so colorful.
You've got all the, I mean, the curry,
then the toppings, the
multiple even layers
and levels of toppings that go into this,
and not only the food, but
also we're just staring
into the greenery of the mountains.
It's beautiful, it's beautiful.
So we are all sitting down to eat.
I'm gonna just like taste a little bit of,
thank you.
(laughing)
Yes, a little more chili oil on there.
And you can see, the difference between
the tomatoes that were
cooked, within the curry,
they've sort of like slightly dissolved
and are sort of like mixed into the stew
and made it tomatoey,
but then you've also got
the umami fireworks tomatoes that were
literally lit on fire for a few seconds,
or for many seconds, and you can kind of
stir it around, look at
that, look at the chunky
beautifulness of that.
So thick compared to any other version
of (speaking foreign language) I've had.
Whoa.
(laughing)
The tomatoes.
When we were sampling it,
like you could taste the paste,
you could taste the
(speaking foreign language).
But then the tomatoes sort of,
now as they dissolve more,
you can see how they've mingled into that.
Sort of toned down the
(speaking foreign language),
but also--
- They're the same group.
They are umami.
So the (speaking foreign language),
the soy sauce, they're all umami,
and the tomato's also an umami,
so she joins the group very easily.
And then we have the
pork, the chicken feet,
the blood, they're all umamis, right?
- [Mark] The umami fireworks tomato.
Is that too much in one bite?
- No, I don't think so.
- And maybe a piece of blood, then.
(laughing)
Yeah, that is a fully loaded bite.
This is the (speaking foreign
language) in there, too.
Mm, mm, oh.
It hits you like, after
you sink your teeth
into the tomato.
We have smoky, but like
deep fried at the same time,
tomato skin, and then it
just bursts into tartness
and juiciness.
Did I get some tomato
splotches on my chin?
That's successful.
So you can find (speaking
foreign language)
just throughout markets and
little local restaurants
throughout northern Thailand,
and it's a very favorite dish,
but most of the versions that I've had
are quite watery and they're more,
yeah, they're just much more watery.
Not nearly as many tomatoes
or spices or ingredients
that go into theirs,
but this one is not watery at all,
even though it's water based,
it's thick and rich
and you taste vibrantly
the tomatoes, as well as all those
other fermented ingredients.
It's sensational.
Yes.
Thank you so much, Hanuman.
Awesome.
- Thank you.
For inviting us to share
such an amazing dish.
- My pleasure.
- In your dream.
This is beautiful.
- Yeah.
And also.
The dish, the cooking, the
food, which is delicious,
but the knowledge and
the stories behind it.
That also makes a huge difference.
- Well, cooking is about humans.
Is about making new friends.
It's about politics, it's about war,
it's about trade, it's about immigrations,
it's about natural resources,
it's about our health.
There are so many layers
that you can scrap through
when you're eating a dish.
So, we're at least fortunate
to have another layer,
which is friendship,
that we can put on top of
all of that.
So welcome, it was really
my pleasure having you.
- Thank you so much.
(speaking foreign language)
- [Hanuman] I like it very much.
- Oh, you taste the dark
soy sauce in there, too.
When you get that much.
- That's why you get
the nice glaze, otherwise
you wouldn't get the color.
Because the black soy sauce has molasses.
That's what makes it black.
So you put it into the whole oil,
you get some caramelization.
- What a day, what a cool day, man.
Thank you.
- I'm quite the passive host.
You know, it's a self service water.
(laughing)
- No.
No, Hanuman has been taking care of us
is what he means to say.
Like fully.
- And even, we're the travelers.
He's telling us stories and feeding us.
- And with coffee at the end to finish off
just an experience of a meal.
Oh, cheers.
Cheers.
- Cheers.
(laughing)
(speaking foreign language)
- Mm.
Oh I can smell the
(speaking foreign language).
Turkish coffee with the view.
Yeah, things cannot get better than this.
And now the light is changing
so it's really like bright green.
I'm still processing
the entire experience,
but I mean, it was more than just a lunch
and a meal, it was an entire
educational experience
and the food was unbelievably good,
but the location, the
atmosphere, the friendship.
He's so passionate and so
knowledgeable about Thai food
and even Thai history,
which ties in so much
into Thai cuisine.
And you learn, I mean, just
in spending a few hours
with him this afternoon
today, I learned so much
about (speaking foreign
language) and then so much
about Thai history and the process.
And even on top of that,
also about ingredients
and the layers of flavor and taste.
It's such a sensory, such
a well rounded experience,
all wrapped up into Three Trees Doi Saket
in a beautiful location.
And Hanuman is offering professional
cooking courses, total immersion programs.
But even single day classes.
So you can check out what he has to offer.
I'll have all his links in
the description box below.
But he is so knowledgeable.
He's a walking encyclopedia
of Thai cuisine and history.
And again, go follow Hanuman
and I'll have all the information
in the description box below.
I want to say a huge thank
you to you for watching
this video, please remember to give it
a thumbs up if you enjoyed it.
Leave a comment below,
I'd love to hear from you,
and if you're not already subscribed,
click subscribe now, and also click
that little bell icon, that
way you'll get notified
of the next video that I publish.
Thank you again for watching.
Goodbye from (speaking foreign language),
see you on the next video.